نعم ، الماء لأقصر معنى للإبرو
يمكننا القول أن الفن السطحي يعني دائمًا الماء
crusi السباحة الاتساق على الماء
يتم رش الدهانات والعديد من ماتي
يمكن نقلها إلى أسطح مختلفة
نسيج خشب سيراميك أو العديد من الأنواع المختلفة
مادة يمكن خطوة واحدة غريبة مياه القمر
أتذكر الرسم
على حد علمي ، أرسم دائمًا
أعرف في شرق تركيا
أشرقت الشمس في قرية بالقرب من حسن كيف
مكان مهم تحت
في الواقع ، منذ أن كنت طفلاً
لقد نشأت مع الماء ومنذ ذلك الحين
لألعب كل الألعاب التي أستطيعها
أنا أعمل على أقدم ما وصلنا إليه
وفقا لسجلات هذا الفن
حول هذا العام منذ من إيران إلى اسطنبول
من المعروف أن هذا معروف اليوم
العديد من فناني الإيبرو موجودون أيضًا في تركيا.
يعيش وكمحتوى ، هذا الفن
تقاليد ومعتقدات هذا البلد.
على سبيل المثال ، نرى أنه يحتوي على Ebru
توليب هو رمز مهم يمثل الله.
[موسيقى]
نعم هو كذلك
لديك المواد الفريدة الخاصة بك
فرشاة إبرو ، على سبيل المثال ، مصنوعة يدويًا
المادة ه جزء من الجسم وردة فرع و
ويمكن أيضا أن تكون مصنوعة من مواد بديلة.
جزء الرأس أقل من الذيل
وبالتالي ، يتم تطبيق الطلاء على الفرشاة.
عقد مبلغ أكبر
يتم توفير المواد الأكثر إثارة للاهتمام من Ebru.
أحد الموضوعات هو جائزة الماشية.
الأصباغ السائلة نسميها
يقف على الماء وفي النهائي
يتم لصقها على ورقة
هؤلاء الناس سعداء جدًا بمشاهدة إبرو.
موضوع مهدئ
أعتقد أنه شخصي
تجربتي أيضًا مع توتر شديد جدًا
لا تركض أنا أعرف حقا الكثير
يصبح مرهقًا لأنه أثناء القيام بالرخام
في الواقع ، عن موضوعك
لديك مشكلة في السيطرة على الماء
أنت تفعل شيئًا ما على الوجوه
إنه مجرد جزء من العملية
لاحظت وهنا لا حصر لها
فقط في حال كنت متأكدا
أداة يمكنها تحويل الشكل الذي تفكر فيه.
تحتاج إلى المرونة
هذا هو إبرو
هناك إمكانات متزايدة
أستطيع أن أرى وأنا متأكد من ذلك
الفن في أجزاء كثيرة من العالم
أسهل في صنعه بمواد بسيطة
سيكون الانضباط الذي يبدأ
أعتقد
[موسيقى]
اشترك